they're up against the political
leadership that is clinging on to power
and they have used force to do that day
three of protests Lebanon's army and
security forces are being accused of
heavy-handed tactics which are further
inferior ating demonstrators they
haven't left the streets despite the
crackdown and arrests their demands
remain the same the government should
resign in early elections must follow
the response from the ruling Alliance
was clear we don't want the government
to resign if it does it will take one or
two years to form a new government and
the economic crisis will worsen and it
will be made up of the same political
forces but that is what protesters don't
want they want change tension has been
building for months these are difficult
economic times and they blame those who
have been in power for decades for
corruption and the mismanagement many
here are unemployed some can't pay their
children's school tuition fees others
can't buy medicine or pay for their
hospital bills the defiance is palpable
from the region from all religions we're
saying one word we cannot anymore except
you mr. Nasser Allah is giving them
support he's supporting the last miles
that the government has to run no more
yesterday president harina said we have
72 hours these 72 hours I'm not going to
change anything
plans to impose more taxes triggered the
protests Prime Minister saddle Hadiya on
friday gave his political partners 72
hours to come up with alternative
sources of revenue for the budget
it seems the political elite are
scrambling to find a solution but that
appears to have done little to calm the
anger tens of thousands are protesting
but Hezbollah made clear the majority of
Lebanese have not secretary-general
Hassan Nasrallah said if Hezbollah
supporters decide to protest they will
change the equation and balance of power
other Lebanese considered that a threat
and the challenge the Iranian backed
group has a military wing nasrallah also
told those on the streets they won't be
able to topple the ruling Alliance
Lebanon's political and sectarian divide
is deep but those who are raising their
voices are standing united carrying only
the Lebanese flag this is the biggest
nationwide protest in years but there is
a large number of Lebanese whose
allegiance remains with their political
parties it's unclear how much those on
the streets can achieve XANA hodor al
Jazeera Beirut